[Music]
the pheasant is one of the most
sought-after game birds in North America
but populations in the wild have
dwindled to replenish them and also
supply a market for pheasant meat
farmers raise breeding stock and
incubate their eggs to make it more
likely they'll yield chicks
with stunning plumage and an ability to
both run and fly
no wonder the pheasant struts around
each pheasant lays approximately four
eggs weekly April through to July
farm workers collect the eggs daily
before the pheasants have an opportunity
to nest with their intervention the
hatch rate will get a big boost it will
go from 40 percent to at least 75
percent
the farmer washes the eggs and water and
special soap to remove dirt and bacteria
they could infiltrate the shells and
harm the growing chicks
[Music]
she inspects the eggs and rejects any
cracked or very large ones that would
contain a double yolk eggs with cracks
her double yolks won't hatch
[Music]
one last dip and she sets the eggs aside
to drip dry once dry she taps eggs
together systematically and listens if
the tap sounds like fine china clinking
together they're suitable for hatching
but if the tap sounds dull there's
likely a crack by listening she finds
one or two cracked eggs she missed with
the visual inspection she places the
eggs in an incubator rack and transfers
it to a cooling room the pheasant eggs
chill here for a few days the cooling
slows down cell division until the
farmer is ready to put the eggs in the
incubator shake production is time for
two hatches weekly
when the time is right she transfers the
eggs to the incubator the incubator is a
toasty 100 degrees Fahrenheit to mimic
the warmth of a hens body
[Music]
she latches the racks onto an automated
system that gently rocks the log cradles
back and forth to turn the pheasant eggs
turning the eggs routinely is something
that nesting hens do naturally and it's
important without it the developing
embryo could stick to the shell causing
abnormal growth the farmer monitors the
incubator temperature and humidity
several times daily three weeks later
she removes the rack and places it on a
tray lined with cheesecloth she opens
each cradle and the eggs spill softly
onto the tray at this point there are
tiny pits on the shells caused by the
chicks beaks as they attempt to break
through
once on the tray she arranges them close
together in a figure 8 configuration
this way the chicks can feel each other
moving queuing them to break out of
their shells
she pumps water onto the tears of the
Hatcher now the Hatcher is warmer than
the incubator
[Music]
she covers the trays with screens to
keep the chicks from jumping onto other
trays as the water heats up the humidity
increases
this causes the shells to weaken making
it easier for the pheasant chicks to
break out of their shells
after a couple of days the eggs have
hatched
after drying off the chicks are fluffy
and lively
the farmer packs them in ventilated
cardboard boxes freshly hatched they'll
survive sixty hours without food giving
the breeder enough time to ship them
anywhere in the world
that's why pheasants are easier to ship
when their chicks some customers prefer
more mature birds so the farmer raises
some chicks and wire frames for a week
until their legs become stronger then
they move those chicks to other heated
buildings until they're ready to thrive
outdoors some will be kept as breeding
stock others will be sold as food the
rest will be introduced into the wild
and just fly away
[Music]